est ce que tu veux démarrer mais bien
sûr je vais je vais démarrer alors pour
ton anniversaire
si monsieur desmarest qui te ressemblent
pas de sexe pas de nom non non rien de
tout ça tu as 20 juste ça te décris pas
mal classés c'est cyril hanouna quai au
restaurant avec un pote
ils ont commandé deux tartare le garçon
a préparé et tartas et qu il les amène
bien un qui est très franchement plus
gros que l'autre et la série et prend le
gros kia mels à l'assiette à sabatini
you tu fais pas chier toi tu vends le
plus gros tu m'étonnes assiette et cyril
il y bat aurait fait quoi ma place mais
dis moi j'aurais pris le petit me didier
bas qu'est ce que tu gueules tual petit
[Applaudissements]
je te jure que ça me ressemble
c'est vrai on semble tellement ensemble
au franck gastambide bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes très très élégant non merci
[Applaudissements]
le choix
sur les 2000
[Applaudissements]
lamit company à 33,4 sur l'idée de
carreaux très bien mon froc
on va te laisser dire bonjour à cauet
est ce que tu veux parce que c'est vrai
on va démarrer dès pour faire un petit
tour de rue et je comprends qu'on
débranche leurs merdes black 2 to
c'est vrai que ce que les gens attendent
france vad alors moi j'avais une
question d'avoir est ce que c'est un
endroit où on va on teste des shows non
la france aux produits on laisse sa
chance au candidat oui bon je vais
traiter savez contexte des choses ils
sont alors sauf qu'on est en direct
regarder ma carrière ce soir un capi la
membrane teste des choses et bas nous
aussi mais voilà voilà
alors est-ce qu'on commence avec les
gentils et puis au fur et à mesure de la
soirée ça très bien non gérer une petite
très mignonne c'est un mec vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est très mignonne alors oui c'est
vrai mais pas si petit
alors il a volé un vainqueur il est au
lit avec sa petite amie
et puis dit ma chérie j'hésite entre le
le film porno ou le match de foot à lui
dire mais le porno le foot us est déjà
joué on teste le rappelle je redis je
suis pas du genre à mr c'est clair dans
la rue qui y voient à pingouins qui se
balade tout seul et il va voir ce
pingouin et ils l'attrapent par la pâte
et puis ils croisent en fille qui
excusez moi monsieur l'agent mais c est
à ce point qui se balade tout seul le
put alors qu'est ce que je dois faire et
le fric tu dis bah le mais le mieux
c'est de l'amener au zoo un bon il part
en direction du zoo puis le lendemain le
flic et le sonntagsblick
regardez la recroise ce mec avec son
pingouin et lui dit mais écoutez je vous
avais dit de l'amener au zoo et le mec
du belge a emmené au zoo ils adorent et
là on va au ciné maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]